daddy yankee what a big moment you're
getting the icon award express to me
what that feels like
it's such a great honor and I feel
blessed daddy yankee has a lot to
celebrate these days not only is he
receiving the icon award at the 2018
Latin American Music Awards he's also
performing at the show like we've never
seen him before we've heard that it's
gonna be extremely emotional explain to
me what we're gonna see on a Latin AMA
stage we're gonna bring a message of
hope inspiration to all the cancer
survivors around the world you can miss
that one it's gonna be a powerful
performance performing with an orchestra
is something we're not used to seeing
you do on stage however the rehearsals
been going great incredible for me that
was in my bucket list to make a
collaboration with Puerto Rico Orchestra
and I did it and I did it as well that
wasn't one of my biggest challenge in
music I see your father comes to my idea
upon knocking paint a semi on you for
macking painting in body Tony choir or
miss organ oh I don't mind
you sat down with women who are battling
cancer what was that experience like
that must have been so emotional it was
very emotional it was hard for me
talking to them was trying to contain
myself and thanks to their words I came
with the inspiration to make the song
it's a powerful song and the most
important thing that is a message that
can inspire them and motivate them to go
through their testing life right now and
trying to face cancer in a different way
I have to imagine that doing an
experience like that kind of changes you
as a human being what kind of impact did
that experience have on you the little
things that we have in life that we
don't pay attention to it those little
things are very important like family
your children your friends trying to
take every second and make every second
count like after nearly three decades in
the industry daddy yankee reflected on
his career and can't wait for what's
next
27 years ago you started this career
your elevator I get on you're a
superstar around the world reflect on
that what does all that success mean to
you what are you most proud of knowing
different coaches around the world yeah
yeah learning I'm a student every time
you've achieved so much what is left on
your bucket list I know you want to keep
creating amazing music but is there
something else that you haven't got the
chance to do that you really want to do
right now if we're very patching our
music honestly yeah keep creating that's
my motivation every day honestly
[Music]